the teachers union in chicago has voted
to stop teaching students in person the
union's going on strike and chicago
canceled classes today that's the bad
news but one teacher teacher who's
battling cancer has refused to stop
teaching students in person
that teacher is called joe o'cool and
we're honored to have him join us
tonight mr cool thanks so much for
joining us
um to
bless you for this tell us why you've
made this decision
hello
well uh in the previous uh strikes i
already made that decision because
i joined the chicago public schools as a
teacher first and foremost as a teacher
and my role i believe my role
should be inside the classroom with my
students
should not be in the picket line i did
not join cps to be a union member
first and foremost to be a teacher
and secondly
i believe that there are ways to fight
city hall
you don't dangle the plight of the kids
in the middle of the fight
just to seek your demands
there are other ways i believe there are
other ways
i have nothing against the union
but i have something against people
using the union as a tool
for political gain
and that's my stand
and that's why i feel that
despite
my battling cancer
i still have a role to play
right now and just want
to make
my life
relevant somehow the thought that i can
still be of service to my students
and i can touch their lives and make a
difference in their lives
well first of all you can make me cry so
please please stop for what's that i
mean
the fact that you literally have cancer
right now and you're fighting it and
you're not afraid or you you think that
your duty
to the students is higher than your own
the risk that you're taking on is just
so
inspiring i think to the rest of us why
do you think it's important if you could
just explain to teach them in person
rather than over a zoom app
i had done the remote learning for more
than a year with the students
and i've seen the limitations and the
challenges that a teacher
faces
with remote learning
it's not really effective it's not as
effective as doing in-person teaching
and i feel that it's not
also fair
to the parents
or the parents need to be with the
students when they should be earning a
living
so
i think
that the union
should look at it not in a sweeping way
they did a sweeping
manner
on their demands but there are schools
without covered
i have my classroom i have 82 students
and i'm not aware of anyone having
covered
i'm not also aware of a teacher having
copied in my school
so i think it's a measure of
the
administration coming up with ways to
really ensure
safety majors being observed
so i think
the union has to look at it
on a school to school basis it should
not be in a sweeping way because that's
unfair to the students that's not fair
to the parents
amazing
i'm so glad that you came on tonight
thank you very much hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else